monsieur le responsable du département
développement à la direction des primes
madame monsieur nous poursuivons donc
aujourd'hui nos travaux avec votre
audition en votre qualité de directeur
dégénéral délégué de la caisse des
points consignation et vous êtes
accompagné notamment de Monsieur Pierre
Laurent qui est responsable du
département développement à la direction
des prés de la banque des territoires
Monsieur Olivier sechel vous êtes depuis
2020 directeur général délégué vous êtes
également directeur de la banque des
territoires qui regroupent les offres de
la caisse d'EPO et de ces filiales au
service des territoires en décembre 2020
le ministre de l'économie et des
finances Bruno Le Maire et la ministre
du Logement Emmanuel vargon que nous
avons auditionné vous en confiez une
mission qui visait à proposer des
solutions concrètes permettant
l'émergence d'offres adaptée à la
massification de la rénovation
ambitieuse des passoires énergétiques en
particulier
celle occupée par des propriétaires
modestes que ce soit en maison
individuelle ou en copropriété cette
mission vous l'avez conduite et elle a
donc débouché sur une publication en
mars 2021 d'un rapport dont certaines
préconisations ont été intégrées à la
loi climat et résilience de 2021 votre
audition doit aujourd'hui nous permettre
de mieux comprendre les conclusions de
votre rapport ainsi que les conditions
de sa mise en oeuvre la recommandation
phare de votre mission est la création
de mon accompagnateur rénov création qui
est effective depuis le 1er janvier 2023
vous avez fait le choix dans votre
mission de proposer d'ouvrir l'agrément
d'accompagnateurs à des acteurs privés à
but lucratif cette proposition reprise
par le gouvernement a pu faire débat
notamment au sein du secteur privé à but
non lucratif en raison de crainte pour
l'indépendance et la neutralité du
conseil en rénovation énergétique et
pour tout dire de l'écho délinquance
dont souffre le secteur de manière
récurrente pourquoi avoir fait ce choix
quels sont les solutions pour amener la
confiance par ailleurs comment juger
vous le déploiement de ce dispositif
votre rapport proposé également comme
solution de financement non pas le
développement du tiers financement que
vous jugiez trop complexe si mon
souvenir de votre audition de l'époque
est juste mais la création d'un prêt
hypothécaire qui a été introduit dans la
loi ou en sommes-nous de la distribution
de ce prêt quels sont les banques
impliquées quels sont les ménages
bénéficiaires et combien sont-ils et
pour quel type de travaux
je voudrais aussi vous entendre sur les
actions de financement de la rénovation
énergétique par la Caisse des dépôts et
consignations et plus particulièrement
du logement social
quels sont selon vous les enjeux dans ce
secteur au regard de la santé financière
des opérateurs quel est votre approche
sur la proposition de seconde vie des
bâtiments qui est proposé par l'USH
l'Union sociale pour l'habitat enfin la
rénovation est aussi une question de
politique industrielle et de
construction d'une filière économique
quelle est la vision de la caisse des
points et conciliation comment
s'engage-t-elle pour relever ce défi
avant de vous laisser la parole pour
répondre à ses premières questions et
pour un propos introductif d'une
vingtaine de minutes il me revient de
vous indiquer que cette audition est
diffusée en direct et en différé sur le
site internet du Sénat et qu'un
compte-rendu sera publié je dois
également vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête serait passible des peines
prévues aux articles
434-13
434-1 14
434-15 du code pénal qui peuvent aller
de trois ans à 7 ans d'emprisonnement et
de 45.000 euros à 100000 euros d'amende
je vous invite donc à prêter serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
a levé la main droite et à dire je
mesure
je le jure je vous en remercie donc je
vous laisse la parole et ensuite notre
rapporteur et nos collègues ici présents
vous poseront certainement d'autres
questions merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente et
je suis très heureux de pouvoir
rapporter aujourd'hui devant votre
commission sur la rénovation thermique
d'autant plus qu'on avait eu un échange
vous en souvenez lors de la loi qui
avait été passée et donc il y a une
certaine continuité dans notre
conversation sur la rénovation
énergétique et donc c'est extrêmement
gratifiant de pouvoir donner suite de ce
rapport qui comme levé indiqué
a eu mise en œuvre finalement assez
rapide assez efficace de la part du du
gouvernement de l'époque peut-être en
introduction commencer par rappeler et
c'était l'une de vos questions ce que
fait la Caisse des dépôts et la banque
des territoires pour la rénovation
thermique car il vous a pas échappé que
si la mission était sur les logements
privés ça ne fait pas partie des mandats
confiés à la Caisse des Dépôts que de
s'occuper des logements privés et vous
le savez mieux que quiconque puisque la
Caisse des dépôts est placée sous votre
supervision avec l'assemblé
international nous sommes placés sous la
protection spéciale du Parlement et donc
la commission de surveillance dans
laquelle siège de sénateur c'est bien
que n'appartient pas à la Caisse des
dépôts de gérer les logements privés
alors ce que c'est en revanche la Caisse
des Dépôts c'est qu'elle a en charge
la rénovation du logement social et
c'est pour ça que je suis venu
accompagné de Pierre Laurent et que nous
nous sommes engagés depuis maintenant de
nombreuses années dans la rénovation
thermique des logements sociaux et
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on peut dire que
c'est un succès c'est un succès au
regard de l'état du parc du logement
social par rapport à l'état du parc
privé qui est que l'on prenne sous
l'angle des performances énergétiques ou
tout simplement des étiquettes très en
avance alors très en avance pourquoi
j'ai envie de dire
il n'y a pas de mérite à l'un par
rapport à l'autre parce que les
bailleurs sociaux sont des
professionnels de l'immobilier ils ont
des équipes professionnelles dont c'est
le métier que de prendre en charge un
parc immobilier de parc prendre en
charge un patrimoine et de l'entretenir
ce qui n'est évidemment pas le cas des
particuliers qui ont tout à chacun un
autre métier alors si on tire un peu le
bilan par rapport à ce que fait la
Caisse des Dépôts depuis 2009 c'est
500000 réhabilitations de logements
sociaux
avec 20 milliards d'euros de mobilisés à
travers essentiellement le fond
d'épargne c'est-à-dire le livret A dont
on parle beaucoup qui sert à la
rénovation thermique et cet
accompagnement donc
recense ce qui a obtenu un gain
énergétique de 40% minimum ou la teinte
d'une étiquette D
je signale au passage que la Caisse des
dépôts qui s'est engagée avec le mandat
le nouveau mandat du directeur général
Eric Lombard très résolument vers à la
transformation écologique fait non
seulement la rénovation thermique des
logements sociaux mais aussi la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments
publics qui est un sujet très important
les bâtiments publics c'est ce sont les
écoles ce sont les bâtiments communaux
les collèges les lycées et que depuis
cinq ans nous avons rénové un million de
mètres carrés de bâtiments publics
évidemment dans le logement social en
raison de logement dans les bâtiments
publics c'est plutôt en nombre de 2
mètres carrés
alors pour aider à ces objectifs là je
voudrais signaler que on a essayé d'être
le plus innovant possible
vous savez j'ai un passé qui vient du
digital et j'avais fait dans ma
recommandation toute une partie sur la
plateforme mais nous essayons aussi
d'appliquer ces outils d'innovation pour
favoriser la rénovation thermique et je
voudrais signaler un outil que nous
avons mis en place gratuitement à
disposition des collectivités locales
qui s'appelle priorino qui est un outil
qui collecte en temps réel toutes les
consommations d'électricité et de gaz
nous les connectons chez ni10 et chez
GrDF pour permettre à l'élu d'avoir une
priorisation de sa rénovation c'est à
dire que nous lui disons sur une
cartographie voilà l'école Victor Hugo
avenue Gambetta c'est elle qu'il faut
commencer par rénover en priorité par
rapport à d'autres écoles et ça a eu un
très très grand succès puisque plus d'un
millier de collectivités locales on
souscrit un
cet outil qui leur permet d'avoir une
première reprise de conscience et un
premier programme de travail alors j'en
viens maintenant à l'essentiel de vos
questions sur donc ce rapport
et c'est recommandations alors vous
l'avez rappelé madame la Présidente la
première de mes recommandations donc
c'était l'accompagnement et d'avoir un
accompagnement des déménages ce qui
m'avait frappé lors de cette mission
c'était de voir à quel point les ménages
étaient démunis et comme vous l'avez le
signalé lorsqu'on est démuni fin c'est
un problème technique c'est la porte
ouverte à tous les abus et à toutes les
codeslinquance et donc
ma recommandation a été de dire que ça
ça devait être du rôle de l'État même si
et c'est dans les questions qui ont
figuré vous m'interrogez à juste titre
savoir quelle est la place des
collectivités locales et que le rôle des
collectivités locales et bien je me suis
dit que sur des politiques de rénovation
qui étaient assez coûteuses de l'ordre
de 3 milliards l'accompagnement
représentait en financement si c'est
pris en charge par la puissance publique
300 millions juste 10% et que cet
accompagnement devait avoir un standard
national quelle que soit le point du
territoire en outre-mer que je sois en
milieu rural en milieu métropolitain en
quartiers ou en milieu montagnard cet
accompagnement devait être le même pour
tous les Français et donc prise en
charge par l'État en sachant qu'en
revanche
sur le fond de l'aide c'est à dire pas
l'accompagnement mais la rénovation
elle-même la liberté pouvait être
collectivité locale et je me souviens
très très bien des différents échanges
que j'avais eus avec des élus qui tous
avaient et très légitimement en fonction
de leur mandat et de leur politique et
de leur programme avaient des objectifs
différents je me souviens d'une
discussion avec Pierre-Yves présidente
de l'euro métropole de Strasbourg qu'ils
aient nous à l'euro métropole nous
voulons favoriser les matériaux
biosourcés et donc nous sommes prêts à
aider plus les rénovations qui se feront
en matériaux sur C je me souviens d'un
échange avec Patrick vergrid le maire de
Dunkerque qui disait moi je veux mettre
un effort sur des quartiers pour
commencer à faire des rénovations de
quartier et chacun avait son programme
et je me disais que s'il y avait que 10%
qui était assurés nationalement par une
prise en charge par l'État les 90%
restants donnaient une liberté
d'expression pour chacune des
collectivités pour orienter les
politiques mais non pas sur le mais sur
le fond de la rénovation et sur
l'essentiel de ce que devait être l'aide
alors après choix lucratif pourquoi
parce que on s'est aperçu quand même que
c'était un marché que manuellement
mon rapport évalué à 250 300 millions en
se disant il faut que ce soit rémunéré
juste valeur et puis on voyait un petit
peu en faisant les différentes
modélisations que c'était un marché et
je pensais qu'il fallait ouvrir ce
marché le plus possible à des
prestataires mais à des prestataires
agréé par l'État et contrôlé par l'État
et c'est vrai que j'étais un petit peu
étonné de voir après cette problématique
de du conflit d'intérêt émergé qui me
semble assez facile de contrôler à
posteriori par les services de l'État
qui donnent leur agrément et qui en plus
rémunère et donc on pouvait très
facilement détecter le sujet qui avait
été évoqué c'était dire vous savez si
EDF par exemple prendre sur ce marché
ils vont prioriser uniquement de
l'électricité et si GDF rentre sur ce
marché enfin engie ça va être que du gaz
écoutez si on voit ça et que au bout de
100 rénovation il y en a 99 qui sont
vers le gaz ce sera quand même assez
facile de le contrôler de le détecter et
puis de dire que vous avez un problème
et donc je trouvais que c'était un petit
peu dommage de faire un procès à
bénitieux sur le conflit d'intérêt alors
qu'on a tout à fait des moyens de
contrôler ce qui se passe et je trouvais
que c'était plus intéressant d'ouvrir
euh ce métier de l'accompagnateur Renov
le plus largement possible parce que les
besoins sont considérables et ma
première proposition c'était vraiment de
généraliser l'accompagnateur rénov et de
le rendre obligatoire ce qui a été fait
à partir du 1er janvier pour faire quoi
au final pour vraiment accompagner les
ménages dans
trois domaines qui sont absolument
critiques d'abord la phase du diagnostic
de comprendre ce qu'il faut faire dans
la rénovation je me suis aperçu et et je
suis parti de l'utilisateur c'est un
petit peu là je pense le côté original
de ce rapport de partir de 17h que
le ménage était perdu il y avait un
chauffagiste qui venait qu'il lui disait
voilà il faudrait prendre tel type de
chauffage qui correspondait généralement
au type de chaudière qu'il avait
l'habitude de vendre puis le ménage se
disait je vais prendre quand même un
deuxième avis le deuxième avis contre
disait totalement le premier en lui
expliquant que si chauffagiste avait
proposé ça c'était parce qu'il était
vendeur exclusif de ça puis se disait je
vais prendre un troisième avis un
troisième avis il disait mais ça sert à
rien de changer le système de chauffage
si vous n'avez pas fait l'isolation donc
il faut commencer par l'isolation oui
troisième et je vous dites mon Dieu tout
ça est bien compliqué est-ce que je
pourrais avoir quelqu'un sur lequel
m'appuyer en toute fiabilité en toute
indépendance pour me dire ce que j'ai à
faire
la deuxième chose c'était le plan de
financement il y a beaucoup d'aide une
voix aurait été de
simplifier tout le dispositif de
financement mais vous voyez la
discussion que j'avais eue avec les
rométropoles de Strasbourg et plein
d'acteurs disons que chacun veut aider
c'est très bien s'il y a une multitude
d'aide en revanche il faut que cette
complexité elle soit prise en charge par
quelqu'un qui soit capable de faire le
plan de financement Le plan de
recensement des aides
et à l'analyse le tiers financement les
modèles que nous avions vu qui
reposaient selon l'idée c'était une des
recommandations de France stratégie il y
a une question qui a été posée par votre
commission
reposer un peu sur l'idée que on
pourrait y avoir une espèce de
martingale où les économies d'énergie
pourraient financer les travaux et
franchement on a eu beau chercher on n'a
pas trouvé la martingale
certes les rénovations permettent de
baisser la facture
elle permet de baisser la consommation
mais malheureusement le prix du
kilowatt-heure je crois que la crise
actuelle l'a montré il est pas fixe et
donc vous pouvez avoir 20% d'économies
mais si le prix de l'énergie augmente de
20%, ça suffira pas à faire compenser
les travaux qui ont été payés à un temps
et puis même les comportements changent
vous pouvez très bien avoir un chauffage
électrique et puis avoir une rénovation
thermique qui se passe bien
et puis décidé de vous équiper d'une
voiture électrique ça n'a rien à voir
avec la rénovation thermique mais votre
facture d'électricité elle va quand même
augmenter donc ces modèles de tiers
financement ne m'ont pas convaincu ils
sont adaptés à certains cas je prends
des copropriétés où je pense des
systèmes dans lesquels très
collectivement il y a des performances
qui peuvent être encrasées par des
contrats de performance énergétique mais
elle ne pouvait pas répondre à la
problématique majoritaire qui est la
rénovation de la maison individuelle
donc deuxième mission pour
l'accompagnateur Renov vraiment
travailler le plan de financement
troisième mission pour l'accompagnateur
Renov accompagné dans le durant la phase
des travaux c'est ce sont des phases
assez angoissantes et il y a des choses
qui il faut être un peu critique sur le
le recommandations que j'ai faites vous
m'avez demandé où en est le prêt avance
rénovation
ce prêt avancer rénovation il est
distribué aujourd'hui par deux banques
La Banque Postale et le Crédit Mutuel
mais il n'y a eu que quelques dizaines
de préavancer rénovation qui ont été
signés et
pour avoir un peu interrogé les réseaux
bancaires en disant comment ça se fait
que ça ne parte pas puis il y avait
quelque chose que je n'avais pas vu et
je le reconnais bien à un moment qui est
un blocage se préavancer rénovation on
avait voulu le faire pour les ménages
âgés qui n'ont plus accès au crédit et
le problème c'était que vous demandez un
prêt avancé pour une rénovation globale
mais quand vous êtes dans une rénovation
globale bien souvent il faut déménager
il faut déménager pendant la période de
travaux et là vous avez une réticence
extrêmement forte à déménager même si la
solution de financement existe
c'est extrêmement angoissant de
déménager il faut trouver une solution
pendant les travaux et finalement les
ménages
se résignent à ne pas faire la
rénovation
renonce parce que ça veut dire un
déménagement qu'on peut peut-être
envisager lorsqu'on a un peu plus jeune
un peu plus mobile
mais que quand on a un certain âge
et donc s'il y avait certainement une
deuxième version à voir ce problème de
l'accompagnement aussi à l’hébergement
temporaire durant la durée des travaux
devraient être prises en compte et je
reconnais que ça je ne l'avais pas vu
alors ça a été quand même travail assez
rapide c'est fait en trois mois
alors j'en viens peut-être aux autres
questions et puis après je si vous êtes
d'accord on aura un système un peu plus
interactif sur les éléments de filière
alors je pense que
il faut il faut envisager deux éléments
de structuration de la filière la
formation et la formation aux
accompagnateurs hanov et la formation à
ces métiers la banque des territoires y
participent on a financé quelques écoles
de rénovation je pense notamment à
l'école de la rénovation énergétique à
Bordeaux et qui avait été initié par
Thomas Cazenave dont on sait
l'engagement sur ces sujets et ça je
pense que c'est extrêmement important
parce que ce sont des métiers techniques
dans lesquels on va avoir beaucoup de
besoins et aussi la filière industrielle
où on a paradoxalement
de grands acteurs amont je pense à
Saint-Gobain dans les matériaux de
rénovation mais dans les métiers en
proximité de
l'usager on a plutôt on est plutôt dans
le monde de l'artisanat on n'a pas de
grands groupes et c'est peut-être pas
une mauvaise chose d'ailleurs mais c'est
tous ces secteur là qu'il faut
encourager
enfin je termine par votre question sur
la seconde vie
que nous soutenons et là je peux vous
dire donc le gouvernement
accordé le droit à l'expérimentation sur
900 logements en
donnant une aide de 16000 euros par
logement qui transiteront par le snap le
Fond national des aides à la
pierre exactement et pas la propriété
puisque on est dans le domaine du
logement social pour expérimenter cette
seconde vie à laquelle nous nous croyons
beaucoup parce que notre pays connaît
actuellement
une vraie carence dans la construction
de logements tous les indicateurs sont
au rouge et donc l'idée d'avoir la
seconde vie du bâtiment qui permet de
reconstruire des logements sans
artificialiser puisqu'on est dans la
seconde vie du bâtiment et me semble
très très prometteur voilà je voulais
pas de plus long dans cette introduction
pour avoir le temps de répondre aux
différentes questions
coucou Monsieur le Directeur général
délégué je laisse la parole à notre
rapporteur
merci merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur le
le directeur général délégué
merci pour votre vous explications et
pour le balayage de du sujet moi j'avais
plusieurs plusieurs questions peut-être
enfin en tout cas de précision par
rapport à ce que vous aviez est-ce que
vous avez évoqué donc notamment sur
peut-être sur le sujet de
l'accompagnement à la rénovation
sur les sur Oui la travailleur
excusez-moi je me relis sur le sujet de
l'accompagnement à la rénovation et les
collectivités sur la question des
collectivités les collectivités locales
par contre ce qu'elle ne risque pas
d'être incité à ce à se désengager et
c'est vrai que c'est des questions qu'on
avait eu par rapport à d'autres
auditions sur le fait qu'on avait les
dispositifs qui étaient en place alors
qu'ils pouvaient être très différents
suivant le
si on les territoires
mais en tout cas qui avait le mérite
d'exister et où sur lequel on avait des
systèmes justement d'accompagnement et
c'est vrai que dans la création du
dispositif mon accompagnateur rénove il
peut y avoir la crainte à la fois que
comme l'État prend en charge que du coup
il puisse avoir un peu un désengagement
des collectivités sur cette sur cette
partie là et sur cette accompagnement
voir si dans votre dans votre rapport en
tout cas c'était des choses que vous
aviez que vous aviez pu
identifier
vous créez vous parliez aussi d'un
dossier unique vous en avez un petit peu
parlé dans mon service rénov et du coup
savoir pourquoi du coup cette cette
proposition en tout cas n'est pas allée
n'est pas allé au bout c'est vrai quand
on est auditionné je crois que c'était
Julien de Normandie nous disait que
pour lui il était assez opposé justement
cette idée de guichet unique en disant
que c'était peut-être quelque chose sur
lequel oui il faut le papier ça pouvait
ça pouvait fonctionner mais qu'on avait
plutôt
[Musique]
du du territoire
et puis également sur l'autre question
aussi où on s'est déjà posé sur la
neutralité l'indépendance des
conseillers sur ce sur ce dispositif
parce que c'est vrai que c'est pas
encore on va dire totalement clair sur
le type d'acteur et et pour le coup leur
indépendance
sachant que ce qu'on a pu voir c'est que
sur la campagnement il y a besoin
justement d'avoir une confiance quoi et
ce rapport de confiance entre la
personne qui qui va faire cette
rénovation elle a besoin du coup de
s'adresser et d'avoir justement cette
totale confiance et donc pouvait se
poser cette question justement de la
de l'accompagnement donc savoir si voilà
si c'est quelque chose aussi que vous en
parlez dans votre rapport mais c'est
quelque chose que vous pouvez voir en
tout cas avec le début de ces
accompagnateurs de ces accompagnateurs
et neuf voilà peut-être pour l'instant
et puis je laisserai mais mes collègues
aussi intervenir et puis peut-être
d'autres questions par la suite merci
vous laisse répondre à monsieur le
rapporteur
sur les collectivités locales vous aviez
vraiment raison et je relisais bien dans
le rapport ou page 17 je disais que sur
le cahier des charges il faudrait une
consultation nationale et locale mon
idée était que l'accompagnateur est
neuve était agréé par l'État mais devait
passer une convention avec la
collectivité locale où il opérait ça
voulait dire quoi très concrètement on
avait un architecte on avait un bureau
d'études où on avait une filiale d'engie
ou solien ou
que sais-je qui
répondait au cahier des charges de
l'État pour devenir accompagnateur Renov
et qui allait un moment se présenter à
la collectivité locale à l'élu pour dire
voilà je suis Olivier Sichel
j'envisage sur votre territoire d'être
au copains rénove et je viens me
présenter je viens d'avoir l'agrément et
j'aimerais passer avec vous une
convention parce que je vois que vous
avez une maison de l'habitat je vois que
vous avez déjà fait des dispositifs et
je veux être sûr de bien articuler avec
vous en sachant que bon la
recommandation que je faisais c'était
que
l'accompagnement était pris en charge
par l'État pareil dans toutes les
collectivités locales mais que sur les
travaux il puisse avoir cette discussion
exactement et qu'avec la maison de
l'habitant disant bah nous on a une
par exemple Amiens dont on vient de
financer le réseau de chauffage urbain
on a une politique de chauffage urbain
on a un réseau de chauffage urbain voilà
un petit peu comment va être le schéma
de chauffage urbain et si vous pouvez
demander un raccordement au réseau de
chauffage urbain on est prêt à se mettre
d'accord sur une subvention ou de dire
écoutez c'est très très bien que vous
interveniez chez moi merci je vous
signale que j'ai fait une école de la
rénovation énergétique j'aimerais bien
plutôt que ce soit avec les entreprises
du quartier comme ça donc je voulais
avoir cet articulation là mais voyez le
parti pris de ma recommandation c'était
l'accompagnement ça doit être
républicain et équilibré pour tout le
monde les aides sur le fond ça ça doit
être moduler localement parce qu'il y a
des réalités territoriales et que bah on
fait pas la rénovation énergétique en
Martinique et pas la même que en Savoie
donc voilà comment je je voyais les
choses pour ne pas du tout avoir un
dispositif
uniforme qui fasse fille des réalités du
terrain et je me disais qu'il y avait de
la place pour tout le monde parce que
vous avez vu les chiffrages dans mon
rapport c'est quand même on parle quand
même de montant en plusieurs milliards
donc on n'est pas refusé des aides on
n'est pas refusé de dimensions dans ce
domaine là alors après sur sur la
plateforme moi ce qui m'a frappé dans
cette politique de la rénovation
énergétique c'est que par rapport au
montant engagé on avait finalement assez
peu de données de pilotage on avait
certes des données de pilotage en
montant de ma prime rénov accordée en
montant en nombre de de rénovation ou de
monogestes fait mais ce qui nous
intéresse tous autour de la table c'est
à la fin combien de tonnes de CO2 j'ai
évité de chauffer dans l'atmosphère ici
accessoirement j'ai réduit la facture du
ménage et ça je trouvais quand même que
essayer d'avoir un outil qui permet de
centraliser l'information et d'avoir ces
données pour piloter et pas et t'es pas
une mauvaise chose
alors après sur l'outil je constate que
dans un premier temps Lana et c'est
absolument normal parce que c'était Lana
pour moi qui était changer de cette
mission à beaucoup informatisé le
dispositif m'imprime rénov et ça a été
leur priorité et je crois que comme ils
ont un moment beaucoup souffert des
délais d'instruction et de ce qu'on me
revient c'est que il y a beaucoup de de
dossiers en souffrance de paiement et
c'est pas anormal ils ont été
complètement submergés il faut voir
quand même la montée en charge qui avait
eu faire la narre moi je salue la
personne manque de cette agence qui a dû
véritablement faire face à un afflu
considérable de demande et qui a fait
une diégétalisation et une
informatisation de ces processus très
accéléré avec quand même pas mal de
sécurité il y a eu il y a pas eu de
détournement il y a deux dispositifs
dans lesquels on a connu des
détournements et donc je pense que cette
idée de plateforme elle est pas
abandonnée mais la priorité a été pour
Lana de faire face aux demandes de ma
prime rénove à leur traitement et à la
sécurisation aussi de l'ensemble de ce
processus
voilà alors je sais pas si vous aviez eu
l'occasion de le voir mais j'avais
accompagné mon rapport d'un petit film
qui expliquait dans un monde idéal ce
que serait la chose ou donc on partait
de nouveau de l'usager en disant voilà
l'usager le ménage il appelait son
accompagnateur Renov
qui lui posait de questions pour
dégrossir le sujet combien de mètres
carrés quel était sa facture
énergétiques est-ce qu'il était
propriétaire est-ce qu'il était bailleur
ensuite il lui organisait la prise de
rendez-vous avec l'accompagnateur Renov
qui venait faire le diagnostic thermique
chez lui il lui envoyait le diagnostic
sur la plateforme et on avait sur une
plateforme tous les diagnostics une fois
que ce diagnostic a été fait et c'était
une numéro recommandation du rapport
c'était d'avoir deux deux propositions
une BBC et puis une un peu plus modeste
de de de rénovation de façon à ce que le
ménage et le choix puis un plan de
financement en disant voilà voilà quel
est votre plan de financement et que ce
plan de fin il puisse être interconnecté
avec les grands financiers et notamment
Lana que tout ça soit dans une
plateforme et que souvent dans la
rénovation c'est de dire
l'entrepreneur il peut commencer à faire
que s'il a payé l'avance mais l'avance
il est payé par Lana que si les choses
sont faits et puis vous avez des effets
de prix financement on a quand on fait
un monde qui peuvent parfois un petit
peu long et puis ensuite d'avoir un
modèle de suivi de la consommation
d'énergie voilà alors c'était
effectivement assez ambitieux assez
prospectif plutôt pour une vision 2030
que une mise en œuvre tout de suite
et sur les zones blanches ça je
il faudrait demander plutôt au ministère
parce que j'ai pas fait le suivi de tout
le rapport donc ça je peux pas vous dire
s'il y a des zones manches actuellement
dans la couverture
ce que je sais c'est quand même on est à
date a quand même 2100 conseillers et
qu'on a 450 espaces France rénov
recensés à date et je j'ai l'impression
que c'est pas mal alors est-ce que ça
peut être plus c'est difficile de voir
quel est le maillage
simplement par rapport à nos auditions
précédentes donc on a auditionné vous le
savez tous les ministres depuis 2012 en
charge de la transition écologique et ou
du logement et
la ministre wargon elle a fait état du
fait que
l'accompagnateur rénove était plus un
accompagnement technique
et que pour elle c'était important aussi
d'avoir un accompagnement qui soit plus
social à destination bien sûr des
ménages qui soient les plus précaires
alors quelle comment vous voilà pour
vous comment vous ressentez cette
proposition et puis il y avait aussi
madame Pompili qui a fait état d'un pour
elle d'un déficit de communication pour
mon accompagnateur rénov qui serait on
n'a pas fait l'expérience en tout cas
moi je ne l'ai pas faite difficilement
repérable quand on va sur le site
Internet de France rénov et ma prime
rénove est-ce que vous vous avez eu ce
type d'information ou est-ce que
véritablement c'est quelque chose qui
pour vous aujourd'hui
fait peut-être alors sur le le deuxième
point ça je pourrais pas vous dire parce
que je suis pas moi-même aller sur
France rénov donc je vais de mal sur le
point de la ministre Emmanuel vargon je
suis d'accord et c'est pour ça que je
vous disais quand on fait le bilan du
très faible du prêt avance rénovation ce
que tout le monde vous dit c'est que ce
prêt avance rénovation il avait quelle
cible il avait la cible des ménages âgés
et il faut savoir que 62% des passoires
thermiques sont occupés par des ménages
de plus de 60 ans donc c'est là où vous
n'avez plus accès au crédit
et où
le
mais en même temps vous avez la maison
est remboursée donc il y a pas de dette
donc ça avait une bonne idée mais
je connais j'ai pris le sujet d'un sujet
tel qu'on le pose trop trop souvent je
trouve dans l'investant thermique sous
l'angle financier quel financement quel
financement quel financement et après
quand on est dans la réalité du sujet
j'en vous disent mais même si vous me
faites un prêt même si je n'ai pas rien
à payer puisque j'ai qu'à payer les
intérêts c'est pas ça le sujet le sujet
c'est que
j'ai pas confiance dans les travaux et
puis j'ai pas envie de déménager pendant
trois mois et est-ce que je serais sûr
que ce sera terminé pendant trois mois
et où je vais aller pendant ces trois
mois comment ça va se passer et ce qui
est valable pour les personnes âgées les
aussi pour les personnes les plus
démunies et les plus fragiles donc c'est
vrai qu'il y a un volet social à faire
que que l'on
maîtrise très très bien dans le volet du
logement social ou peut-être pierre tu
pourras un peu parler mais dans la
partie
rénovation des logements sociaux
j'en visite beaucoup et cette partie
d'accompagnement social est très très
fort je vais donner un exemple de ce que
c'est l'accompagnement social la tour
Cézanne à Arras qui est une grande tour
dans un quartier des favorisé de la
ville d'Arras dans lesquelles il y a à
peu près 100 ménage plutôt à grande
hauteur si vous connaissez aras on a
fait un magnifique projet de rénovation
qui est par l'extérieur ou on étend ent
à peu près 11 mètres carrés chacun des
logements en faisant en fait une
extension en verre qui fait comme une
espèce de petite véranda
pardon et exactement exactement et bien
il y a eu Frédéric le Turc me disait il
y a eu six mois de consultation de
travail avec chacun des des
locataires
locataire assez
âgé et qui avait qu'une préoccupation
c'est à dire comment ça va se passer
pendant les travaux puisque là on est
sur une rénovation qui qui dure plus de
deux ans et sur lesquels il faut
communiquer communiquer communiquer
prendre le temps d'entendre le temps de
faire un consensus aussi de savoir ces
mètres carrés comme on va les faire
rassurer tout le monde qu'il y aura pas
d'augmentation des loyers démontrer que
les économies d'énergie seront bien au
rendez-vous et donc ça on le fait assez
systématiquement dans le logement social
parce que des bailleurs sociaux ont
l'habitude de se dialogue social dans le
parc privé on sait pas le faire on sait
pas le faire et je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui reste à prendre en
compte
des questions à poser non monsieur le
rapporteur
peut-être un petit complément sur le sur
la question des filières industrielles
savoir sur la manière de ce que vous en
avez parlé parlé rapidement sur la
manière de la CDC d'intervenir justement
cette question de filière et c'est vrai
que on s'aperçoit que sur la question de
la rénovation thermique
c'est indispensable en tout cas la
question d'affiliaire de dématériaux qui
souvent à manquer pour pouvoir pour
pouvoir réaliser qu'à la question des
entreprises qu'il faut former également
et avoir le l'ensemble pour pouvoir
réaliser l'ensemble des CE2 ces travaux
et un point particulier sur les
matériaux biosourcés puisque bon on
s'aperçoit qu'actuellement la plupart
des matériaux utilisés on est encore
très loin justement d'utiliser du
biosourcé et qu'on voit qu'on a un vrai
intérêt à pouvoir le développer
localement que ce soit chaud ou la
paille fait un peu importe le type de
type de matériaux le bois également et
que ces filières c'est vrai que c'est un
gros travail de mise en place et
notamment de mise en place locale quoi
et donc est-ce que sur votre
accompagnement qui soit financier en
tout cas ce que c'est des choses sur
lequel vous avez une attention
particulière
voilà notamment sur sur la question du
biosourcer ça me paraît ça me paraît
important et puis j'en profite je
voulais revenir sur un autre point tout
à l'heure vous avez parlé des opérateurs
en sangliers en disant que
enfin vous avez dit que enfin voilà
l'idée de France stratégie était pas
forcément
pas forcément la meilleure on va dire
pour être pour être pour être simple
et parce que voilà le
principe est de se rembourser justement
sur l'économie d'énergie puisque c'est
c'est un peu ça dans leur dans leur
principe et qu'effectivement c'était
comme une énergie à la fois
l'augmentation des prix d'énergie à la
fois le fait que on peut avoir des
comportements différents une fois que le
logement que le logement est isolé
mais du coup on a on a reçu une une
proposition de enfin des citoyens on va
dire qui ont fait une proposition de loi
qui s'apparente pas tout à fait mais qui
est un peu dans le même dans la même
réflexion qui est de dire en fait si on
veut vraiment avancer sur la rénovation
thermique il faut à la fois passer sur
l'obligation mais du coup s'il y a
obligation ça veut dire en gros un reste
à charge zéro et que l'ensemble des
travaux soient pris en charge et l'idée
et l'idée qui est mise c'est de du coup
qui est un fond fondational de la de
rénovation et qui soit alimenté
donc forcément se font se font se font
rénovation
attribué des prêts pour réaliser les et
c'est prêt il y aurait l'hypothèque sur
sur l'habitation et cette hypothèque du
coup le prêt serait remboursé à la
session du logement ou alors au bout de
30 ans si le logement n'était pas
n'était pas cédé sachant que une grosse
partie en moyenne des logements de toute
façon sont
déjà façon cédé dans les dans les 30 ans
et ça veut dire que ça nécessite
évidemment un fond assez important et du
coup un système de prêt qui soit assez
important avec ce remboursement via ce
système d'hypothèque donc voilà du coup
je voulais savoir aussi si vous aviez
c'est quelque chose que vous aviez déjà
entendu en tout cas et votre avis sur
cette sur cette proposition là
de nouveau je pense qu'il faut pas
prendre ce sujet là uniquement sous le
prisme financier
je vais vous donner un exemple par
exemple sur lequel on travaille beaucoup
avec Pierre qui est la rénovation des
bâtiments publics qui sont à la charge
des collectivités locales que vous
connaissez bien au Sénat exemple les les
lycées pour les régions les collèges
pour les départements et puis les écoles
pour les communes
l'argent ne manque pas c'est le livret A
qui qui les finances la durée ne manque
pas puisque nous nous pouvons prêter à
20 ans à 30 ans à 40 ans même à 50 ans
nous avons des dispositifs dit d'in
tracting ou nous pouvons
identifier les économies d'énergie dans
le budget pour autant le parc public est
très en retard pourquoi parce que quand
je discute avec avec les élus et j'en
vois beaucoup le sujet n'est pas tant
financé le sujet c'est une conduite de
projet assez lourde une connaissance du
patrimoine a établi
une
des appels d'offres à passer avec
parfois des contraintes sur l'emploi on
sait bien que les entreprises ne sont
pas suffisantes donc
ça ne peut pas la solution ne veut pas
être financière
et là on a vraiment des des
interlocuteurs qui sont assez purs dans
la mesure où ils savent très très bien
faire je vais avoir tel budget pour la
rénovation thermique et je vais avoir
tel dépense d'énergie quand vous êtes
dans le diffus dans la maison tous ces
dispositifs qui est Didier je vais faire
un fond et je vais me retrouver sur les
économies d'énergie
et ce sera sur une longue durée
généralement parce que on sait bien que
c'est des amortissements qui vont durer
15-20 ans ça veut dire que à un moment
et je pense qu'il faut aller au bout de
la démarche et je les fais avec le les
équipes de France stratégique dire qui
s'assure de l'engagement du ménage
d'avoir un comportement qui ne change
pas et qui reste le même pendant toute
la durée du prêt et dire que la
construction intellectuelle est
attractive intéressante mais un moment
quand on ce qu'on va avoir monsieur et
madame seichel qui dit voilà votre
innovation c'est 80.000 euros et vous
vous engagez à avoir la même facture
énergétique chez engie un même type de
consommation pendant les 20 prochaines
années je sais pas et alors on dit ça va
être garanti par engie EDF mais ça
dépend d'un prix du kilowattheure est-ce
que vous pensez Kenji EDF ont été en
mesure de contrôler leur prix du
kilowatt-heure ces deux dernières années
ça a complètement bougé donc c'est c'est
il y a il y a la construction était
intellectuellement attractive mais dans
sa mise en oeuvre opérationnelle je ne
sais pas la mettre en oeuvre et je ne
vois pas non plus de fond capable
d'encaisser les variations de l'énergie
et déjà on avait quand même fait ce
rapport et et
écarter ces scénarios là avant de
connaître l'explosion des tarifs de
l'énergie donc je pense que c'est
intellectuellement stimulant intéressant
mais ça ne me semble pas
répondre à la problématique alors
après sur les filières
chaque fois qu'on le peut on est
vraiment en encadrement des défiléens
sur maison et cité qui est vous savez le
patrimoine des mineurs du Nord c'est
65000 logements dans l'ensemble du
bassin minier il se trouve que ce
patrimoine ayant été classé à l'Unesco
les rénovations ne peuvent se faire que
par l'intérieur donc elles sont coûte
magasin vous êtes à l'avenir et un
investissement thermique c'est 40000
euros là vous êtes à 80000 à 120000
euros et ça dit en passant pour amortir
par l'économie d'énergie 80 000 à
120.000 euros vous voyez un petit peu ce
que la taille du fond qui va falloir
faire là on est complètement en
structuration de la filière je crois
c'est du c'est du lin ou du chanvre donc
c'est du chambres c'est le chanvre avec
que l'on fait autre démarche de
structuration de la filière qu'on qu'on
a qu'on a fait
et qui n'a pas donné tout tous ses
succès parce qu'elle est tombée en plein
dans la crise inflation c'est de
l'énergie c'est la démarche énergie
sprong je sais pas si ça vous dit
quelque chose l'énergie sprogue c'est
une marche qui vient de
du Pays-Bas
où
sprong c'est un saut où on se dit il
faut que le bâtiment soit un
consommation 0 et donc on va
systématiser et massifier les commandes
pour arriver à cet objectif en baissant
les coûts de la rénovation et en étant
systématiquement en recherche d'une
consommation nulle et donc ce qu'on a
ici de faire on l'a fait avec l'Union
Sociale de l'habitat des Pays de la
Loire on a regroupé une dizaine de
bailleurs sociaux en leur demandant de
mettre par type les différents logements
du logement claté du logement des années
70 du logement passoire thermique de
façon à passer des appels d'offres
massifiées et pas faire de la rénovation
immeuble par immeuble avec un artisan
qui vient mais véritablement de dire
voilà vous allez avoir un marché de 500
logements à rénover qui ont toutes les
mêmes caractéristiques pour essayer de
structurer ce qu'on a vu au Pays-Bas
c'est que par exemple à ce moment-là
vous arrivez à structurer une filière
qui va faire de la fabrication hors site
et qui va prendre des métrés et qui va
venir après poser les métrés de façon
industrielle
au lieu de commander 20 pompes à chaleur
vous en commander
400 du même type et donc que vous avez
des effets de structuration de la
filière et de massification de la
filière alors malheureusement alors la
démarche à bien fonctionner on a eu des
appels d'offres et on a eu plusieurs
logements qui ont été dans cette filière
mais pas la hauteur de ce qu'on
attendait parce que la la filière était
quand même très très touchée par
l'augmentation des coûts de construction
et par l'inflation
le dispositif mon accompagnateur rénov
est incontournissant puisque vous l'avez
dit il est donc il s'est mis en place au
1er janvier 2023 est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
avec le peu de recul dont vous disposez
est-ce que vous semble être conforme à
ce que vous attendiez à ce que vous
préconisiez et ensuite au niveau
financier est-ce que là aussi la
dotation budgétaire me semble-t-elle
suffisante
ça franchement là j'ai pas pu suivre les
les l'évolution des dotations
budgétaires et puis c'est quand même la
responsabilité du gouvernement mais
j'ai été invité par Lana
au congrès de tous les accompagnateurs
rénov et moi j'ai été frappé à la fois
de du très fort engagement de la
profession
vraiment très animé d'une mission
d'intérêt général une mission de service
public
et qui était plutôt plutôt submergé par
la tâche en disant
il faut qu'on soit plus nombreux pour
répondre aux besoins des clients et
plutôt en faveur des recommandations que
j'avais faites en disant il faut
vraiment un accompagnement dans le temps
du ménage pour être efficace et surtout
surtout la reconnaissance qu'ils avaient
c'était de dire que
si on veut de l'efficacité dans la
rénovation énergétique ça ne peut pas
être que le monogeste et que il
privilégie beaucoup la rénovation
énergétique globale mais que la
rénovation énergétique globale ça peut
se faire que vraiment avec un
accompagnement global de gens qui ont le
niveau et l'expertise nécessaire pour le
faire et vraiment c'est ça que j'ai
retenu c'est à dire que
enfin vous sortez juste du monogest qui
est je refais un petit bout d'isolation
de mes fenêtres je change ma chaudière
sans prendre vraiment le sujet
globalement pour obtenir la vraie
performance dans la rénovation
énergétique du logement
bah tu peux prendre la parole
je suis désolé c'est un peu formalisé
mais il faut que vous prêtiez serment
aussi et que vous disiez je le jure mais
voilà comme ça au moins on est
je le jure très bien allez-y donc c'est
pour compléter les propos d'Olivier sur
le PLF 2023 avec des ambitions et des
moyens sur ma prime rénov qui ont été
vraiment revisité à la hausse avec un
budget de milliards près de 2000 heures
et demi donc en croissance de 25%. donc
ça on peut vraiment se féliciter de des
efforts qui ont été qui ont été
attribués à ce dispositif
j'avais juste une petite question
complémentaire pareil dans votre rapport
vous parlez des des contrôles plus
complets
sur justement les travaux de l'étranger
de rénovation thermique et tout à
l'heure donc on a auditionné Lana nous
disait que sur les les contrôles réels
fait sur site en fait c'était à peu près
10% qui était fait puisque la plupart
des
contrôles qui font sont sur dossier quoi
en fait sur les sur les devis mais qui
font quand même 10% de de contrôle sur
site et du coup je voulais avoir votre
avis justement sur cette sur cette
question là parce que c'est vrai que
c'est un aspect dont on peut se poser
des questions sur à la fois
l'orientation qui peut être donnée de
dire on va labelliser des entreprises
notamment RGE en se disant bah à partir
du moment elles sont labellisés du coup
on estime que les travaux qui sont
réalisés sont corrects
mais en réalité derrière à la fin il y a
pas de ce soit pour les versions de mon
attention etc il y a pas de il y a pas
de contrôle sur site ou très peu
et c'est vrai qu'on pourrait inverser
les choses et un peu sur ce qui se fait
sur l'assainissement de dire qu'en fait
on a on a un contrôle systématique en
tout cas sur la réalisation des travaux
en fin de en fin de chantier qui va
déclencher justement le le l'aide
voilà du coup avoir votre votre avis par
rapport par rapport à ça puisque c'est
vrai qu'on se rend compte qu'on a quand
même quelques soucis sur des rénovations
qui peuvent en tout cas en termes de
qualité et d'objectif à atteindre qui
peuvent parfois laisser un peu à désirer
[Musique]
que vous souhaiteriez porter votre
connaissance
un collègue
merci beaucoup madame